okay so not even two weeks ago a guy
called malice who's one of the only non
Koreans to ever play for a Korean League
of Legends team dropped a litany of
allegations against his own or the BB Q
Oliver's allegations including
psychological abuse threats and failure
to pay players now with the battle lines
drawn between Western and Korean League
fans things got pretty heated online
pretty fast but just a few days after
all this happened malice apparently
apologized and the whole thing was swept
under the rug
so what the hell happened here
all right so before we get into this
series of unfortunate events that
unfolded over just a few days let's
figure out who the players in this
little game are sebastian at home AKA
malice is a Swedish League of Legends
player who until recently it was signed
to the BB Q Oliver CK T you see malice
is something of a trailblazer after all
he was the first foreign player to ever
play in challengers Korea you take a
hyped foreign player a team that was in
the lck but fell from grace being
relegated the first team out of lck
obviously is pretty embarrassing and you
have the recipe for a pretty incredible
underdog story and had things turned out
differently hell I think we here at the
school resource probably would have done
one of our eSports documentaries on that
underdog story but that's just not how
things worked out so on October 9th
malice drops a new sport classic they
twit longer airing a litany of
grievances except this one includes a
little more than the usual visa issues
or late payments among all of these
grievances he alleges that BB Q Oliver's
failed to pay him for three months and
have a history of delayed or late
payments for the rest of the team
threatened physical violence against
players and coaches said one manager
inappropriately touched players in the
form of unwanted back rubs that members
of management lost or took items that
belonged to malice including allegedly
his passport that BB Q Oliver's failed
to provide proper equipment where the
coach at the time LS allegedly had to
pay out of his own pocket to give them
workable pcs that at times vbq Oliver's
failed to feed them take out the trash
or do the laundry that they manipulated
players through deceit and lying and
that they apparently ignored pleas for
help from the players and coaches all
this contributes to what malice paints
in the TWiT longer as an environment
that's extremely negative and toxic it
got to the point where malice says that
team members had to leave the team house
and actually play at PC bongs in order
just to get away from the stressful and
negative environment that was permeating
the team house even says once he got
kicked out of the team house on
short notice in the middle of the night
with nowhere to stay basically this
whole situation on both sides was just a
giant mess and it couldn't be resolved
easily which I guess led to malice is
twit longer and his public airing of
grievances now all of that from Alice's
perspective sounds pretty damning but
let's pump the brakes just a little bit
for some context here now if you're not
up on your Korean League of Legends you
should know that malice has a history of
acting questionably for example shortly
after he joined the team in 2018 he came
under heavy fire for some pretty toxic
stuff that he said and did in soloqueue
some of which was characterized as
racist then in January of this year
there was more controversy where malice
apparently acted in a toxic way during a
game with lck caliber top laner antara
as far as I can tell this includes but
might not be limited to excessive
pinging in a solo q game yada vbq
Oliver's coach at the time LS kinda
beefed with him tarah on Twitter
antara responded on stream and the whole
thing got outta hand but we're not done
here later in the year malice was
suspended three games by Riot Games and
given a sentence of community service
all related to toxic behavior in
soloqueue now does any of this mean we
shouldn't believe what malice is saying
about the situation at beta Q Oliver's
no of course it doesn't in fact it would
defy all common sense to imagine that
this guy just made all this up
speaking of rich malice dropped his
original twit longer on October 19th now
just a couple days later BB q Oliver's
responded with a ginormous Facebook post
and 10 different YouTube videos they
featured the orbs CEO and director Seon
Chang song apologies if I'm
mispronouncing that and in those videos
and in that Facebook statement he tries
to refute most of what malice alleges in
fact according to a translation
independently sourced by the score
eSports this guy paints a pretty
different picture than what malice told
us he says that all throughout 2019 mal
acted disrespectfully to the entire or
he miss practices disrespected coaches
and management and didn't play the games
he was supposed to be playing at the
time he was supposed to play them he
would apparently leave the team house
and come back and just continue to
behave in a way that BB Q Oliver's paint
as well badly
apparently malice wanted to quit the
team in July and BB q Oliver's
themselves wanted to terminate his
contract as well
in August according to the translation
we have of the BB Q Oliver's Facebook
post it was determined by that org that
due to analysis numerous alleged
contract violations that they would cut
his pay and soon now fast forward to
October 18th according to the same
Facebook post malice and BB q Oliver's
agreed to the terms of termination of
his contract but when he showed up at
the team house malice apparently demand
it to be paid for the prior three months
and threatened to expose the org Griffin
style if that didn't happen see our
recent don't at me on the Griffin
scandal for more on that now as for the
rest of mouse's specific allegations
well the CEO does try to refute some of
them for example he says he never
threatened anyone with physical violence
and never screamed or raged in front of
the players he says there are certain
specific banking errors that led to
delays and payments for some players at
certain times in regards to the lack of
food and alleged poor team house
conditions and he blames it on a move in
locations in the team house but he does
say that when that happened during the
affected period there was a plan put in
place to make sure there was adequate
food for the players I hope so
on the subject of the allegedly unwanted
massages and touching from the manager
known as Barham the CEO simply says that
that person no longer works with baby
koala vers honestly not sure what to
make of this one he doesn't really
address the concern here now the CEO
refused to address the allegations that
LS the coach had to provide equipment
for the team or that LS had been
threatened with physical violence in the
team house in front of the players
before we move on one small note here in
interacting with the story it seems
clear to me that part of the context
here especially when it comes to you
know the Western fans being really on
malice aside and the Korean fans being
really against him is a cultural clash
of values I think some of the stuff that
that malice does is obviously a bit of a
dick move but a lot of us here in the
West kind of feel like well you
shouldn't have done that
you should chill bro but in other
cultures there may be a bigger deal or
there's cultural significance that we
don't particularly understand or take
for granted now I'm not excusing any
behavior on BB Q Oliver's or malice but
I am saying that when you put a young
man who has a history of toxicity into a
house with other young men in a
completely different culture in a
foreign land some shits not going to go
well now there is more to the statement
of course a lot more including those ten
YouTube videos and there is a publicly
available translation of it on reddit if
you care to sift through malice for his
part responded to the response reading
that reddit translation on the street at
this point things are getting so heated
that you got to imagine it's all gonna
come to a head but just a day later BB q
Oliver's dropped this statement on
Facebook here's what happened according
to a translation of the statement
independently sourced by the score
eSports someone translating for and
representing malice reached out on
October 22nd to BB q Oliver's
apologizing for his actions and asking
for leniency or relief from the lawsuit
that BB Q had been pursuing apparently
malice came to the team house in person
apologized but
a suit was dropped the contract was
terminated and everybody just washed
their hands of the whole thing okay
that's a good resolution I guess but
there are so many loose ends still
hanging out there like we're all of
malice --is more damning accusations
actually authentic
what does ls have to say on the subject
what about that guy who tweeted that he
had designed the BB q Oliver's uniforms
and never got paid what about the
defamation lawsuit we've heard of
against malice from the guy he accused
of inappropriately touching him there's
actually a ton there and if you guys
would like us to look into any of those
threads well I suggest you drop a
comment and we'll see what we can do all
right so I almost hesitate to say this
and it's good that it's at the end of
the video so a lot of people have
already clicked off but I'm like reading
this story right and I'm like okay
malice is the worst guy in the world
according to whomever look I'm sorry
okay
you gotta play one game of csgo
matchmaking you're gonna hear some [ __ ]
that's gonna change your [ __ ] life
you're gonna want all the excessive
pinging you can [ __ ] handle no
disrespect
no disrespect to my League of Legends
players out there I just thought it was
funny hey some csgo you'll appreciate
you're going to hear some
twelve-year-old say some [ __ ] that you
that you never want a human being to
ever say again